the economies change radically the
problem with saying everybody has to
work in the office is you won't be able
to hire the best talent when we went out
for financial services people in our
operating company the best talent told
us if I have to come into an office and
sit in the cubicle and drive for 45
minutes each day into a war-torn city
like San Francisco which we were trying
to hire in I'm not doing it I don't want
to get shot on my way to work safety in
large cities like Chicago San Francisco
you know some parts of New York City LA
these days nobody wants to work in these
places they're War zones and so they
want to work where they get their job
done and the reason it works is project
management if you say everybody has to
come to the office you'll get the third
tier candidates you're not going to get
the El Supremo yeah and I care about
talent I want great team members and if
they tell me I don't want to work in an
office but I'm number one at what I do
I'll go with the number one with what
good point yeah